today we're talking about security
gaming advancements and a new region
i'm vicola and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
cloud armor google cloud's ddos defense
service and web application firewall
waff help customers protect their
websites and services
we work constantly to stay ahead of the
evolving threat landscape
and are excited to announce a few
updates
including the preview of cloud armor
adaptive protection
a machine learning powered capability to
protect your applications and services
from layer 7 ddos attacks four new
pre-configured
waf rules and a reference architecture
check out the blog for more details
developed in collaboration with embark
studios quillkin
is a udp proxy tailor made for high
performance
real-time multiplayer games with quilkin
our aim
is to pull common functionality and
provide this common functionality in a
composable
and configurable way leading to a
reusable foundation that allows game
developers to spend more time on
building the game
specific aspects of building their
multiplayer communication protocols
rather than the common aspects to
support customers
and public sector in india and across
asia pacific
we're excited to announce that our new
google cloud region
and delhi national capital region ncr
is now open designed to help both indian
and
global companies alike build highly
available applications for their
customers
the delhi ncr region is our second
google cloud region
in india and our attempt to open in asia
pacific
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you